una rueda grande gira con una velocidad
angular 4 o mega una rueda pequeña gira
a la mitad de la velocidad angular como
se compara el periodo de grande de la
rueda grande con el periodo de pequeña
de la rueda pequeña pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolver esto por su cuenta y
vean qué opción elegirían aquí el punto
clave es darse cuenta de la relación
entre el periodo y la velocidad angular
en lugar de memorizar la fórmula a mí me
gusta deducir la a que es igual el
periodo bueno para completar un ciclo si
se trata de un movimiento circular
uniforme vamos a recorrer un círculo así
y para recorrer un círculo completo
vamos a completar dos radiales así que
vamos a recorrer dos y radiales y vamos
a dividir esto entre la velocidad
angular que tan rápido recorremos los
radiales así es como me gusta deducir y
recordar esta fórmula que relaciona la
magnitud de la velocidad angular con el
periodo podemos decir que te grande es
igual a dos irradian es entre el
enunciado nos dice que tiene una
velocidad angular de 4 o mega así que
dividimos
y entre 4 o mega de pequeña es igual a 2
radiales entre su velocidad angular que
el enunciado dice que es igual a la
mitad de la velocidad angular de la
rueda grande es igual a 2 pi entre la
mitad de 4 o mega que es 2 o mega como
se comparan estas dos cosas una buena
idea es simplificar ambas cosas antes de
comparar las de grande es igual a pi
entre dos o mega y te pequeña es igual a
ti entre un mega esta expresión de la
izquierda es la mitad de la expresión de
la derecha reescribimos esto como un
medio por pi entre omega otra forma de
escribir t grande es un medio por esta
expresión que es igual a t pequeña cuál
de estas opciones coincide con lo que
acabamos de calcular es la opción b de
grande es igual a un medio aporte
pequeña si tienen tiempo siempre es
buena idea verificar que el resultado
tenga sentido una rueda grande gira con
una velocidad angular 4 o mega una rueda
pequeña gira a la mitad de la velocidad
angular si esto tiene la mitad de la
velocidad angular entonces va a rotar
a mitad de rápido y si está rotando la
mitad de rápido entonces le llevará el
doble de tiempo completar un ciclo a la
rueda pequeña le tomará el doble de
tiempo que a la rueda grande también
podemos verlo cómo queda la rueda grande
le toma la mitad del tiempo que a la
rueda pequeña para completar un ciclo
hagamos otro ejemplo una patinadora gira
a una velocidad angular 2 o mega ella
extiende sus brazos disminuyendo su
velocidad angular a 'omega' cómo cambia
la frecuencia de su giro nuevamente los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de encontrar la respuesta por su cuenta
aquí tenemos que pensar en la relación
entre la frecuencia y la velocidad
angular
recordemos que el periodo es igual a 2 y
radiales que es lo que se recorre para
completar un ciclo y lo dividimos entre
la rapidez con la que se incrementa el
ángulo nuestro periodo es 2 pi entre la
velocidad angular si queremos conocer la
frecuencia entonces tenemos que calcular
el recíproco del periodo la frecuencia
es igual a omega entre 2 pi es el número
de ciclos que se pueden completar en un
segundo la patinadora gira con una
velocidad
angular de 2 o mega en este caso la
frecuencia inicial es igual a la
velocidad angular de 2 o mega entre 2 y
la frecuencia final que es cuando la
patinadora extiende los brazos y
disminuye su velocidad angular en
futuros vídeos hablaremos más de este
fenómeno
el enunciado dice que su velocidad
angular disminuye a omega por lo que la
frecuencia final es omega entre 2 pib
como se comparan estas dos frecuencias
reescribimos la frecuencia inicial y
queda igual a 2 por omega entre 2 pi que
es igual a 2 por la frecuencia final
otra forma de pensar en esto es que la
frecuencia final si dividimos ambos
lados entre 2 es igual a un medio por la
frecuencia inicial si la frecuencia
inicial es el doble de la frecuencia
final la frecuencia final es la mitad de
la frecuencia inicial como cambia la
frecuencia de su giro pues parece que su
frecuencia disminuye a la mitad esto
tiene sentido si la velocidad angular
disminuye a la mitad la rapidez de la
rotación disminuye a la mitad también y
solamente podemos completar la mitad de
los ciclos por cada
así pues tiene sentido que la frecuencia
disminuya en un factor de 2 esto es lo
mismo que decir que multiplicamos la
frecuencia por un medio nos vemos en
otro vídeo